[Music]
do you guys remember the uh migrant comp
boy from that was like moving from south
america oh yeah like a ton of them yeah
they're moving through like all the
south american countries working their
way up north migraines
was like stop coming into our country
yeah yeah i remember that that's right
they were trying to get in the united
states you're trying to get united
states from all the way from like south
america and they were like traveling as
a group yeah yeah i remember that well i
don't know whatever happened to that
because they just stopped reporting on
it but um
do they stop that they always do now
there's another one there's like it was
a safe shot yeah they're playing 15
minutes yeah but uh basically there are
a bunch of uh
there's another group desperate migrants
have
sewn their mouths shut in a protest
demanding that they be able to travel
over 1 000 miles through mexico to the
u.s border you mean like they [ __ ]
sold it this is what people don't
understand like these people are
fighting for their [ __ ] lives they
got real problems i guess most of them
are from venezuela that's what i said
venezuela yeah and they're trying to get
over to the us but the but mexico won't
grant them the uh the asylum yeah whoa
this is like this is what i always feel
so bad for man because honestly if they
don't do some of the [ __ ] like this
nobody gives a [ __ ] nobody gives a [ __ ]
yeah
and they'll just stop reporting on it
you know what's funny so well it's not
funny it's pretty sad but then like back
in the day america used to have this was
mainly during the cold war america used
to have the uh verbiage of okay come
over here immigrants you know you guys
could start a new life here this is the
place right you'll see it in every
presidential speech but then this one
it's like don't [ __ ] come
people thought it would change with
biden but then i think there's something
else happening with the
way that the us is like okay we don't
want more people
or whatever it is because back then it
was a different conversation but because
people thought that when biden got into
office it would change but now he even
outright was like don't come here but
but like that's the definition of
politics kalama was like don't [ __ ]
come here it's [ __ ] crazy
people are coming here and they're
taking the resources from away from the
actual citizens i don't know what but
what does that mean like resources like
they're stealing gasoline like taxes or
like you have the medical care has to
get spread to them that's why you mean
like the counter argument or do you mean
like that's the argument yeah like for
example isn't there like there's those
those guys that were uh they were caught
at the border they were jumping they're
they're hopping the border and then now
um because they weren't given the
vaccine they were able to counter sue
for being mishandled right so like so
like now the met like the the medical
resources have to get spread i always
say this and i wonder why no one else
has thought of this why don't they just
put a team of lawyers down there and say
hey you need to bring me like your
criminal record because people are like
the criminals are coming the criminals
are coming why don't they just be like
you're a citizen and now you got to pay
taxes
because that helps the government and
then the complaint of like they're not
paying their taxes which is basically a
misnomer which we were talking about
because a lot of illegal immigrants do
pay taxes don't they just get paid under
the table though that too but they still
have so a lot of people still pay their
taxes and then they've got no benefits
of being a tax payer like let's say they
get fake papers right this is one of the
ways that they do pay taxes it's like
even if you get fake papers and then you
like let's say you work at like i don't
know like a farm or whatever right
they're still getting taxes taken out of
their paycheck before they get their
paycheck just like a regular if it's not
under the table um yeah if it's not but
a lot of farms and stuff uh don't do i
would say a lot of under the table jobs
might be like mom and pop restaurants it
might be it's not done by major
operations because they get audited and
like they're scared of getting caught
yeah because you can't even document
that you paid an illegal immigrant right
in your own records if you're a
businessman you're [ __ ] yeah you can't
actually say you did that right in most
it's not done in major operations but
most people that are hiring are like mom
and pop like for example like a
contractor right like if you own like a
construction company and it's just you
and maybe your brother and then you go
to home depot and you grab some dudes up
and you're like i need help you know
things like that it's done by you know
small operations and sometimes there'll
be a scandal where you find a big
operation doing it but then they're
um they're way too like it's too risky
for them to hire an illegal immigrant i
mean there's also less crime committed
by
immigrants when people like ah they're
gonna be criminals i'm like who's the
criminal
for real the catholic church the dude
who makes the the you know the tahini
sliced mango across the street is
a criminal usually like what usually him
after he works really really hard
provides a good life for the family then
the son who speaks perfectly
then he runs then he becomes the
president of the fda and then runs this
game
that's usually what
the recent immigrants are the hard
working ones yeah that's true it's their
[ __ ] ass kids yeah are we offering
like did all of our parents immigrate
here yes yes
yours was great grandparents well you
have great grandparents probably yeah my
parents did and i was a criminal so yeah
me too
i'm a [ __ ] stereotype i wasn't a
criminal but i was a [ __ ] dude i'm a
criminal
i'm a criminal i'm stealing white roles
yeah that's the good thing oh [ __ ]
i'm the real criminal you're the reason
why
so the argument you're like they're
going to steal my jobs it's it's it's
retail he is you've been stealing jobs
you're stealing jobs from uh since i'm
18 years old baby lizzy's stealing josh
from the whites bro most of these
migrants are from venezuela guatemala
nicaragua republic of the congo these
are all like war-torn countries they're
not poor they're war-torn you don't hear
people like congo's in africa so they
went to latin america first and then
they no because a lot of people will go
well yeah they'll take a boat to south
america and then from there move up yeah
so mexico is blocking them from passing
through
well not like they don't ever want them
to go through but i guess they're not um
they're not waiting to be issued the
visas
because it just takes so freaking long
like i'm assuming these guys also don't
want to land in mexico right they don't
they don't they want to go all the way
through oh but then mexico is like nah
bro because you got to go through they
have to physically i mean they just it's
like with anything like the process is
so long that for people are seeking
asylum that might be too long i might
die in five years yeah they don't have
the resources dude chill in the random
spot it's really [ __ ] didn't it dude
people were complaining you know like oh
if you sent me back to my country i'm
gonna die and then they send these
people and then they're murdered and
they die and people are like ooh i wanna
know the real reason why is it like is
it like they don't have enough money the
government's running out of like what is
it you know because it's usually an
economic reason nothing else
i highly doubt that people make
decisions no no no dude it's definitely
politically voted because let's just say
the president of mexico goes yeah i'm
going to do this then you know whoever
disagrees with him is like we're not
voting for this person period ever again
oh so it's a met you mean like from
mexico it's being blocked i would have
why is it i was thinking about the us no
trump was like i'm building the wall and
half the country was like yeah we're
voting for this idiot
and then they didn't build the wall so
he scammed the country you spent all
this money parks football
with little mexican children doing
see-saws on the border i do enjoy all
the art installations that have come
through this wall i just think it's
[ __ ] stupid dude like they should
just give everyone citizenship let them
all pay taxes and be like what do you do
what are you good at is it painting
houses were you a lawyer in your country
like you got a lot of should it go the
other way too like if you just suck at
being american and you're not throwing
them back over here this is what i'm
saying it's like what do we do there
it's like there's hell of people that
are like failing i bet if you look at
the statistics of people who are
you know like
are criminals
uh dealing with tax fraud or any sort of
uh
let's say bad habits i guarantee you
their citizens in this country are not
people of color
well statistically you know there's more
citizens than immigrants that are
illegally here so obviously there's
going to be way more criminals you know
like yeah but think about it what's the
ratio then is it disproportionate yeah
disproportional yeah it's the same thing
you know so there's actually just a
little factoid there's actually more
immigrants in federal detention now
with biden office than we're before
i'm not surprised though
yeah i laugh at that [ __ ] because it's
just
not part of his promise
yeah they're gonna they're gonna let the
kids in the cages go and he was like way
more kids in them cages i just never
understand why they're like i have a
great idea let's separate the pants from
the kids and then they're like if we if
they die that's not our fault i don't
know that way at least we'll be away
from the parents confusing part is that
biden closed to immigration detention
centers as part of the initiative to
like fight against that and then he
built five more
we just we just consult there's more
people in the ones that are left over oh
my god
because people think like we're the good
side we're gonna solve america and i'm
like don't you [ __ ] know that there's
established dudes that are career
politician on both [ __ ] sides that
are just constantly [ __ ] with the u.s
you know public like it's been like this
for how long and they said that about
obama too right it's been like this for
how [ __ ] long why are there borders
just forget it like we're in the modern
world just oh [ __ ] open it up i got
[ __ ] you know i got easy pass yeah
let's just go back to pangaea yeah
one world government how about that
new world order
someone activates skynet i'm tired of
this [ __ ]
let's let the robots figure it out yeah
dude they got it so what do you think
about like um
about the due process of vetting
people who want to immigrate
well i'll tell you this like so um
i mean i said this story before but my
my girlfriend coming here from the uk
she's on a legitimate visa all that
stuff but she got stopped by border
control and it was a crazy [ __ ] scary
moment because like you know she called
me she's like yeah i just landed cool i
don't hear from her for five [ __ ]
hours yeah and she was treated like a
criminal in there they were
interrogating her not letting her go to
the bathroom like not just violating
right demanding that she unlock her
phone and [ __ ] they wanted to look at
her phone go through her [ __ ] phone
they kept pressing her she's like look
am i here for a reason why am i here
they're like oh it's because of this
this and this and then she's like okay
that's probably illegal and then you
know i was like this is [ __ ] mad they
just wanted to single you out and they
were doing this to other people in there
too and she goes you know what's crazy
is the people that could prove that they
were extremely rich they got out like
that this guy was like from australia
and he goes look i have this much money
in my bank account this is what i do
here whatever whatever and they're like
okay you're free to go and everybody
else
that couldn't really speak english well
they were grabbing them up and [ __ ]
them up dude they're like you're
tripping on that word okay this and this
okay we're saying
but also
but the interrogator was not white
that's why i was [ __ ] up you know what
i mean like
it's like dude you need to have somebody
on that side i guess if we need to have
more resources for the undocumented
people to come through like the u.s
boards and stuff there needs to be a
special interest for politicians to make
money yes correct it all comes out of
super power if there is no
incentive for them to make this a system
they're not going to pour money and
resources into it that's why i say just
make everyone a citizen and have them
fill into the the tax dollars so at
least then the government knows we have
officially put them in the pipeline but
to even start to make money off
dude if the irs wants something for you
they can literally find you in 10
seconds you're telling me they can't
process these people it's literally it's
a one-piece paper they probably just
don't want to set up the system what if
you can't prove that you would be a
citizen of worth
like
like being first uh well i guess like
with my parents immigrating here they it
took so [ __ ] long for them to prove
that what they were studying and what
they were certified for in the
philippines was real and that they would
be able to come here and be a nurse or
x-ray but then like what if you're just
someone that is fleeing a country and
you don't have those you didn't bring
all that [ __ ] yeah but don't they claim
are they claiming like refugees refugee
asylum well either way both of those
processes
who knows how much longer asylum is than
[ __ ] regular but doesn't it all of it
is weird everyone knows that venezuela
is a [ __ ] show it's not like i'm coming
from a village in asia and they're like
you can't verify what's going on they're
like let me check on wikipedia they're
like oh there's a civil war or they
don't have internet well there is
inflation a deflation like
so it's it's the question of like let's
say that you you're legitimately telling
the truth hey i'm coming from like a
war-torn situation i'm here for singing
asylum okay we'll we're just going to
file your stuff it may take months at
that point when you hear that and you go
[ __ ] it i'm jumping the wall yeah like
is that wrong
because that's what's happening a lot of
times i mean look
that's rough dude i think you're going
to do whatever you're going to need to
do to protect yourself and your family
dude imagine leaving so then you get
these people who are sewing their mouths
because they're china if china had a
land border with the us would that
should be exactly the same way
i have a i have a friend who's uh who's
japanese but like culturally mexican
like full japanese right and the reason
why this happened is because um in the
1940s they immigrated to mexico because
they heard that it was easier to go from
mexico to california and then world war
ii broke out and they heard that
japanese people were being rounded up
into camps so their relatives were like
don't [ __ ] come here
so their grandpas and grandmas just
basically stayed in mexico and then
they're like we're just going to be
mexicans and then basically that's what
happened but eventually they made their
way into california to meet their
relatives but that's a funny [ __ ]
story after two generations
they were born in mexico all that and
then they went let's finally go to
america
oh shit's chill all right they're not
rounding up some caps all right let's go
you know what you know the thing is is
like we we're saying this as obviously
minority groups and a lot of us as
immigrant families it's like most people
just have no clue what this experience
is oh yeah yeah yeah no [ __ ] no i do
you're completely ignorant and it's just
like we're american
and it's just like dude you gotta have
empathy i always i always blame you know
like not only the media but then our
politicians who divide us because we
have way more in common with working
class white folks than we do with rich
white folks you know and rich minorities
like it's really a it's more class yeah
with class i bond more with people of
the same class and upbringing than i do
over race and i think that that's the
[ __ ] up [ __ ] with the right and left
issue under the [ __ ] red and blue
issues a lot of that [ __ ] is [ __ ] too
made to divide us and that's what
everyone says about like out like people
that don't live in the states they
always say like you guys in the u.s man
you guys are always so obsessed with
race all the time i know that's you guys
yeah but yeah but
i'll tell you why though
because we just watched a video of two
14 year olds getting fought one kid who
got arrested was the black kid
that's why we're obsessed with 100 it's
why when i'm wearing a mohawk i get
pulled over every single day and not the
white kid
it's because of race it's because you
look like a stereotypical 90s villain
[Laughter]
dude that's why i get searched for bombs
every time i go to the airport
[Music]
[Music]
you